[Music]
if pop culture has taught me one thing
it's that the statue of liberty doesn't
have the remotest chance of surviving
the oncoming storm of natural disasters
man-made disasters or alien invasions
that are no doubt inevitable over the
next four centuries this window is
beautiful but where's the tv supposed to
go look if the future doesn't have tv
i'm not going to be there seriously i
won't have a job why has blue man goop
here evolved emotional ejaculation ducks
above the eyes i don't know whether it's
a fear response or a sexual one but
either way wouldn't you be less likely
to survive if every time you got over
stimulated you couldn't even see where
you were coming or going
nothing to talk about yes there is
nothing at all to talk about just give
me one minute defending your affair with
i can explain this unless of course she
plans on explaining whether this
biological function was premature right
on time or entirely decorative no i'm
still not over that yet i have good news
victor garber isn't talking about
rumbaldi in this scene the uss orville
roll star marshalls one of these mints
those are marbles i'm not sure which to
send that he thought that a marble was a
mint his pinpoint spitting accuracy or
the fact that admiral halsey keeps a
gravy boat full of marbles on his desk
three cents it is this past year the the
tardiness the sloppiness my god
you've been put on report for coming
into work hungover six times i'm already
questioning how much value the planetary
union puts into the well-being of its
people these are all signs that ed is
going through a trauma of some sort and
his captain just put him on report and
stalled his career look i'm just saying
that this isn't how picard would have
handled it i know gordon has his issues
but we all know there's nobody who can
drive a starship like him it's your ship
captain mercer halsey doesn't have faith
that ed is ready to be captain and yet
he's still going to trust his judgment
in picking an equally unstable and
currently grounded pilot does the animal
not like this ship did the crew beam his
dog into space he's a badass fighter but
i gave him a really neat personality hey
dude this is my buddy ed hey ed nice to
meet you i'm justin
[Laughter]
we is this seth macfarlane show actually
going to be funny anyone check lucifer
for frostbite on his pointy tail fine
i'll give the sin back but if this
happens again i'm prepping for the
apocalypse instead hey justin you got a
ladybug on you oh neat
hollow victories why is this manifest in
no discernible order it's not ordered by
rank name or position all the names are
just there why wait don't you guys have
like super strength soleil's
gravitational pull is high compared to
the planetary average so yes luckily for
the audience the silent predilection for
exposition also seems to be higher than
average lieutenant how old are you
asking inappropriate questions did he
not just hear that she can crush him
right in his dangly prejudices all right
uh lieutenant commander bortis our
second officer there are lots of ways to
do character exposition but standing
your cast all in a line and having your
main character literally read off all
their stats and character sheets as if
he's just confirming things they both
already know has got to be among the
most sinful your entire species is male
isn't it that is correct sir so there's
probably not a lot of arguments about
leaving the toilet seat up and that kind
of thing right seth mcfarland leans on a
tired gender cliche for a punchline
cliche cliche yeah nobody was hurt but
300 crates of authentic autumn squash
were sucked into space technically if
i've studied my data on this things get
blown into space from the atmosphere
inside the ship what sucks is that you
don't know the difference is there any
word yet on a first officer i should
have an update in a few hours
sounds like you won't have to wait much
longer and i'm not going to give you any
details yet because boy oh boy do we
have a big obvious surprise planned for
the audience designing this stairway
that leads to the damn command center in
a way that's only wide enough for one
person at a time in fact why does this
place have stairs at all stairs should
never be allowed in space this spaceship
porn drags on and on for so long but
somehow not long enough for it to become
a funny commentary on the genre you're
supposed to also be parroting star trek
seth not just becoming it no
no no no no no no no no no doesn't
matter no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no this is
my ex-wife who i have not seen since my
divorce a year ago after i walked in on
her banging a retipsion skip and i swear
if this show continues with this
marriage story and space drama it's just
gonna keep getting skipped i know this
isn't ideal but she is the only
qualified exo available okay i'm
officially calling shenanigans on this
staff shortage right now there are over
7 billion humans god knows what it'll be
in the 2400s but let's say it's only
doubled to 14 billion out of those 14
billion you can't find a few million
that are willing to fill your fleet of 3
000 ships and i'm not even counting any
of the other species we've seen this is
a galactic contrivance oh no we're
definitely talking about it
at which point everyone stops talking
about it ed
i can't apologize a skip bang papa smurf
in our bed that's for tepsist also papa
smurf's tiny stout and has a beard
literally the only thing they have in
common is that they're blue at least go
with a blue alien like stitch or tsutse
or rainbow dash
admittedly the designer of the orville
probably didn't have this exact
situation in mind when putting the ship
together but there are any number of
other reasons that the captain's office
should be sound proofed captain kirk
taught us that one what happened between
ed uh skip man you could cut the tension
with a knife do not make eye contact no
need to worry you guys are literally
sitting 10 feet away from them they
easily heard your conversation so not
sure eye contact is your issue here i
have to ask did they train this dog to
continuously lick itself on command and
what is that command canine olingus
vitalatio please come down to the
surface i will explain everything and so
begins what feels like a five-year
mission's worth of come and take a look
at this cliches punctuated with hey
isn't the future cool exposition and an
abundance of spaceship boggling i'm
beginning to think there's only a
25-minute episode in here padded out to
45 with melodrama and rejected family
guy bits is that one of your projects no
no that's dr jovika chief botanist and
they're completely naked which i'm
totally fine with but i do find it
interesting how all the sentient alien
life that chooses to wear clothing also
all just happens to be the most humanoid
ones what a strange coincidence i
couldn't tell you the real reason we
needed a union ship because i couldn't
risk divulging the information over open
communications then shouldn't have
maintained the charade until they came
to the planet with the intended supplies
instead he does exactly what he said he
couldn't risk doing as soon as they
arrived in orbit so
it's an anti-banana ray it's really
interesting we need no longer fear the
banana he literally just said janice has
been experimenting with temporal fields
even you can put that together with the
rapidly aging banana and figure out
what's happening here quit being
purposefully ignorant just to get off a
mediocre joke it's really not a good
look
and skip i've read about this
hypothetical quantum field manipulation
of the flow of time is theoretically
possible physician geneticist therapist
and quantum theorist so essentially an
expert in whatever the plot needs her to
be an expert in if she turns out to be
an illegally augmented human in season
five and dr ernoff was in on it all
along i will not be amused you do
realize this could also be used as a
weapon all technology in the history of
humanity ever merced aboard us it's the
2400s and you're still communicating
with a handheld walkie-talkie that
should be installed in our cyborg heads
by the late 2200s and you know it
okay couple of things here a shouldn't
the super dangerous agree be encased in
something to prevent any stray matter or
a human head from being prematurely
matured and b as horrifying as it would
have been shouldn't we be seeing a
hundred years worth of expressions
rather than one long scream i mean from
her head's perspective everything is
still happening in real time this should
have been maybe a few hours screaming a
couple hours of bargaining and then back
to screaming at least spaceship
spaceship spaceship spaceship spaceship
spaceship spaceship spaceship spaceship
spaceship spaceship spaceship spaceship
excitement having a work environment
with only these stools to sit on for the
love of christopher nolan give your
people some lumbar support why does
shooting these door panels always result
in the doors being permanently locked
wouldn't it make more sense for the
doors to automatically stay open once
the thing that opens them can't open
them anymore
deactivating your helmets directly
before a gunfight and not reactivating
them sure sporting of both ships to
agree to fight for a bit on a single
plane instead of taking full advantage
of the 360 degrees of maneuverability
provided by space
nobody gets cauterized by green pews
during this paddle through an open water
feature a water feature that is
surrounded by the cinders of said
pewpews allowing the internal aesthetic
of your 25th century shuttle to be an
influence by 21st century twitch
streamers
all five of these trained officers
somehow managed to miss the krill hiding
around the corner of this tiny shuttle
does no one on television have
peripheral vision give me the device but
it all works out in the end because this
krill thinks that diplomacy is the best
use of his carefully acquired surprise
advantage instead of shooting everyone
in the back he's got a gun
we have something better what
seat belts ed risks having his plan
overheard instead of just doing the plan
nobody needed to know ahead of time what
was happening surprises are exactly why
we have seat belts even if i was the
best helmsman in the galaxy that's
virtually impossible
if you can
hug the donkey
you can do this because all it takes to
turn the virtually impossible into a
sure thing is a motivational pep talk
upper and middle engines are gone
captain i have failed you ships in one
piece sport it is not sorry can you can
you move like two steps to your right
ruining a perfect rule of thirds shot i
just got out of a rough marriage
i have an idea
what is it
let's give them the device i know kelly
gets there eventually but who pitches a
plan by leading with its most outrageous
element she does this so that we can be
surprised when the actual plan happens
does she know we're watching wait
they're directly covering the ray by
gluing the seed to the end of the device
and it still works this works i know
this is desperately trying to be a star
trek tribute but this krill ship is one
cloaking device and a pair of shoulder
pads away from being a copyright
infringement happy arbor day scene does
not contain a captain's log pun also
you're just gonna wipe out an entire
ship with no thought of the lives lost
is this something they have permission
to do did admiral halsey give them a
license to krill also also wood should
not be stronger than space metal you
were always better at solving my
problems than i was skip
skip
skip i said skip what is it the show
broke my skip button
the enterprise show me the bridge of the
enterprise yet chattering and pizza
is that it
that's not bad right so say we all
so what are you doing on a union ship i
am programmed in multiple techniques
a broad
variety of pleasuring
[Music]
is the parking brake on
why are we not funding this
round and round she goes great kid
oh yeah
fire